[Música]
[Aplausos]
bueno desde que yo era niña escuché la
palabra pasión pero ustedes creen que
una niña de este tamaño entendería su
significado pues si creyeron que no
están en lo correcto yo no tenía ni idea
de lo que significaba eso yo creo que yo
le di sentido esa palabra cuando vi por
primera vez a mi hermano a manejar en
los cochecitos go-karts porque esa era
su pasión se veía tan feliz que nunca
más lo he vuelto a ver sonreír como lo
hizo ese día pero tampoco lo he vuelto a
ver llorar como lo también lo hizo
cuando ya no pudo hacerlo
bueno un secreto que tengo es que yo
siempre he querido ser como mi hermano
pero que queda entre nosotros y pues yo
también quiere encontrar una pasión
entonces empecé a probar cosas pero en
ese entonces lo único que me gustaba era
comer y dormir y esa no era una pasión
entonces probé con el ballet pero me
corrieron del ballet porque pues
platicado mucho o sea aquel niña corren
del ballet pues a mí también probé con
la natación
pero mis papás me dijeron que tenía que
aprender a nadar y luego me podía salir
ellos con la esperanza de que algún día
me gustará pero dicho y hecho cuando
aprendí a nadar me salí también aprendí
a andar en bicicleta pero cuando aprendí
creo que no me volví a subir después de
5 años otra vez
y un día fui a la gimnasia pero la
verdad es que no me gustó mucho porque
me peleé con una niña entonces me acabe
saliendo pero por alguna razón regresé a
la gimnasia y nunca antes me había
gustado tanto como ese día entonces yo
fui y le dije a la maestra por favor
exige me porque yo quiero ser como las
mejores o tal vez mejor que ellas
entonces me transfirieron como al grupo
de selección yo estaba como en el grupo
de principiantes y ahí están todas sus
amigas hacíamos relajo platicábamos y yo
tenía la esperanza de que también fuera
en el otro grupo así pero fue todo lo
contrario
pues se secreta van atrás de mí
me decían que no podía entonces pues
ustedes qué grupo hubieran escogido
yo creo dónde están mis amigas pero la
verdad es que yo escogí el grupo de
selección porque yo sabía que iba a
aprender más ahí no importa que llorar
en ese grupo yo sabía que ahí estaba
mejor durante el camino hubo varios
procesos tropiezos no hay una semana que
no me duela algo pero un día me sincé el
cuello muy grave y estuve yo creo que
como una eternidad sin hacer gimnasia
bueno yo lo sentía así pero la verdad no
sé con fe entonces pues cuando volví fue
más o menos volver a empezar de cero y
repetir niveles y todo pero antes yo me
arrepentía mucho de lo que había pasado
porque les decía porque me pasó a mí
ahora que voy también que estoy siendo
mejor cada día
aprendí que las cosas pasan por algo y
si no hubiera pasado eso yo no estaría
aquí hoy hablándoles y cambiaría mi
futuro y la verdad es que me gusta mucho
cómo está
yo descubrí que la gimnasia era mi
pasión cuando mi papá una vez me dijo
hoy solo vamos a llegar 15 minutos tarde
y ya le dije bueno para ti tal vez sean
15 minutos insignificantes pero para mí
son 15 minutos de lo que más me gusta en
esta vida y creo que es muy importante
que todos encontremos nuestra pasión no
importa donde yo lo encontré en el
deporte ustedes también lo pueden hacer
pero también lo pueden encontrar en la
geografía en las matemáticas en las
ciencias leyendo un libro en lo que sea
y para terminar hay una frase que me
gusta mucho que la pasión para entender
que los límites son mentales gracias
[Aplausos]